>> Neil: OHIO REPUBLICAN SENATOR
ROB PORTMAN DOESN'T NEED A
REMINDER WHAT'S GOING ON AT THE
BORDER.
HE'S HAD MEETINGS WITH HOMELAND
SECRETARY MAYORKAS.
HE'S KIND ENOUGH TO JOIN US
TODAY.
VERY GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> HI, NEIL.
>> Neil: THIS TITLE 42 ISSUE
WILL BE DEBATED AT A HEARING.
THIS TAKES EFFECT MAY 23 IF
NOTHING CHANGES, THAT IS
REMOVING TITLE 42.
YOU'RE SAYING THIS GOES BEYOND
WHETHER THAT STAYS OR GOES,
RIGHT?
>> YES.
TITLE 42 IS NOW IN COURT.
THERE'S A LOUISIANA DISTRICT
COURT THAT SAID THE
ADMINISTRATION CANNOT END IT
NOW.
THEY HAVEN'T GIVEN A DAYS WHEN
IT COULD BE ENDED.
SO WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE DATE
IS YET.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS 42 IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH ORDER.
IT HAS TO DO WITH COVID.
AT SOME POINT IT'S GOING AWAY.
WE HOPE COVID IS GOING AWAY.
WE NED A SOLUTION DEEPER THAN
THAT.
THE PROBLEM IS ABOUT HALF THE
PEOPLE ARE BEING SENT BACK UNDER
TITLE 42, THE OTHER HALF ARE
BEING LET IN OUR COUNTRY.
THAT IS ROUGHLY A MILLION PEOPLE
LAST YEAR.
LOOKS LIKE THIS YEAR WE'RE ON
TRACK TO HAVE ABOUT TWO MILLION
PEOPLE.
PEOPLE THAT COME UNLAWFULLY,
APPLY FOR ASYLUM, ALLOWED TO GO
IN AND SPEND SIX TO EIGHT YEARS
WAITING ON THEIR COURT CASE.
VERY FEW ARE EVER SENT HOME.
DURING THE FIRST EIGHT MONTHS OF
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, THE
FIRST EIGHT MONTHS, ONLY 26,000
PEOPLE SENT BY EXPEDITED
REMOVAL.
SO THAT'S THE PROBLEM WE HAVE TO
SOLVE.
WE'VE BECOME A MAGNET FOR PEOPLE
ALL OVER THE WORLD BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THEY CAN CLAIM ASYLUM AND
WORK IN.
>> Neil: DO YOU GET A SENSE WITH
THIS PHONE CALL FROM SECRETARY
MAYORKAS OF HIS PRIVATE DOUBTS
WHERE THINGS STAND AND HIS
CONCERN THAT WERE LEAKED OUT?
DID HE RELY ANY OF THAT, THIS IS
NOW GETTING OUT OF CONTROL TO
YOUR POINT?
>> LISTEN, I'MN'T NO GOING TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT HE SAID IN THAT
CALL.
I'LL TALK ABOUT WHAT HE SAID
PUBLICLY, WHICH IS CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT HE SAID IN THE CALL.
HE THINKS THE SYSTEM IS BROKEN.
IT CLEARLY IS.
NOBODY CAN LOOK AT THIS SYSTEM
AND SAY IT'S WORKING.
MY OWN VIEW, WE SHOULD HAVE
LEGAL IMMIGRATION AND EVEN
INCREASE THAT WITH REGARD TO THE
SKILLS THAT WE NEED IN THIS
COUNTRY.
SO OPEN THE FRONT DOOR A LITTLE
MORE BUT LET'S CLOSE THE BACK
DOOR.
IT'S NOT ONLY ABOUT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, IT'S ABOUT THE DRUG
ISSUE.
THE MOST DANGEROUS OF THE
DRUGSES, PARTICULARLY FENTANYL,
IS COMING IN THROUGH THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
DRAMATIC INCREASES IN THE
NUMBERS ALONG WITH THE DRAMATIC
INCREASES IN IMMIGRATION.
IT'S AFFECTING MY STATE AND MOST
OF THE DEATHS ARE BECAUSE OF
FENTANYL.
SO IT'S ALL RELATED.
THERE'S AN OBVIOUS SOLUTION
HERE, WHICH IS ON A BIPARTISAN
BASIS FIX THIS PROBLEM SO
IMMIGRATION WORKS THE WAY IT WAS
INTENNEDED.
>> SENATOR, WHILE I HAVE YOU
HERE, LOOKING AT THE COMMENTS OF
KEVIN McCARTHY AND HE MIGHT HAVE
MISREPRESENTED HIMSELF OR SAID
HE LIED ABOUT NOT RECOMMENDING
THAT DONALD TRUMP SHOULD RESIGN
IN THE FACE OF THE JANUARY 6th
ATTACK ON THE HILL, WHEN IN FACT
AN AUDIO TAPE REVEALS THAT THAT
WAS A CONCERN OF HIS AND HE WAS
GOING TO PRESENT THAT TO THE
PRESIDENT.
DO YOU THINK THAT THIS IS MUCH
ADIEU ABOUT NOTHING, KEVIN
McCARTHY SHOULD NOT BE THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER IN THE HOUSE
IF THE REPUBLICANS TAKE THE
HOUSE THE NEXT SPEAKER?
>> IT'S MUCH TO DO ABOUT STUFF
THAT I HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH.
THE HOUSE REPUBLICANS WILL MAKE
THAT DECISION.
THEY WILL ALSO I THINK JUDGE
KEVIN McCARTHY ON EVERYTHING
HE'S DONE TO TRY TO ACHIEVE THE
HOUSE REPUBLICAN MAJORITY, WHICH
HE'S ON LINE TO ACHIEVE.
SO I THINK THAT WILL BE
CONSIDERED.
ALSO, THE EMOTION OF THE TIME.
JANUARY 6 WAS A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME FOR ALL OF US UP HERE.
SO LOOK, THAT'S A DECISION HOUSE
REPUBLICANS WILL MAKE.
I DO THINK THEY'RE LIKELY TO GET
THE MAJORITY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
TODAY, IT'S PARTLY BECAUSE OF
THIS BORDER ISSUE, INFLATION.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
FOR A CHANGE.
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR MORE
CONSISTENCY IN TERMS OF HOW WE
DEAL WITH THINGS LIKE THE
BORDER, DEAL WITH STIMULUS
SPENDING THAT GOT OUT OF CONTROL
AND CONTRIBUTED IN A BIG WAY TO
THIS INFLATION.
PEOPLE GET THAT.
SO I THINK THE HOUSE REPUBLICANS
ARE LIKELY TO GET THE MAJORITY.
IN THE SENATE, IT'S LESS
CERTAIN.
RIGHT NOW IT LOOKS LIKE THE
POLITICALLY IT'S GOING TO BE A
GOOD YEAR FOR REPUBLICANS.
>> Neil: YOU MENTIONED THE
REACTION THAT FOLKS AND YOURSELF
HAD, MITCH McCONNELL, AT THE
TIME OF THE JANUARY 6th
UPRISING.BUT IT THEN DISSIPATED
VERY QUICKLY.
IT SEEMS LIKE VERY FEW WERE
WILLING TO TAKE ON DONALD TRUMP
OR TO REHASH THAT.
DO YOU THINK THAT IS BEST NOW
THE WAY THINGS ARE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I ISSUED A REPORT WITH SENATOR
BLUNT AND WE HAD OUR TWO CHAIRS,
AMY KLOBUCHAR AND GARY PETERS.
IT TALKS ABOUT THE LAPSES AND
HOW IT HAPPENED.
I THINK THAT IS GOOD TO HAVE
THOSE REPORTS OUT THERE TO BE
LOOKED AT SO WE CAN A